it's been a long day and you're hungry
so you go to the vending machine looking
for a snack and there's chips skittles
and then there's this interesting snack
in the corner that no one's been eating
what is it science we are in the midst
of an anti-science diet and that the
core of this diet is that interest in
science is declining let's take the u.s.
population in high school that intends
to pursue a degree in science this
number drops dramatically at the
bachelor's level it drops again at the
Masters level leaving just a few
doctoral students who end up completing
their PhDs in this field and for those
that actually get their degrees and stay
committed to this field they don't get
famous for it in fact the most famous
modern scientists are fictional I bet
for some of you the most famous modern
scientist is mr. White from Breaking Bad
a quirky soft-spoken high school
chemistry teacher that makes the big
leap from educator to met cooking drug
dealer science is more than that trust
me so while mr. white here gets all the
glory the real scientists they get stuck
with all the labels at best they're
considered intellectual at worse they're
downright crazy and the adjectives in
between are less than flattering because
of this diet science is missing out on
the opportunity to connect to you and
you as an audience are missing out on
all the information that science can
bring to enrich your life I'm Jackie
grant and I'm one of those few PhD
students that decided to pursue my
doctoral degree in neuroscience here at
Stanford i'm now at Stanford Business
School because I want to make that
science action role and i'm here today
to transform your view of what science
is and what it can be for you which is
snackable snackable science is what i
like to call unintimidating science that
is in
primitive and that you can manage in
bite-sized pieces so where did my love
for science start well none other than
with the prairie dog remember in high
school we all had to do those science
projects maybe yours was dissecting a
frog or mapping out the solar system
with styrofoam balls well I remember
mine and it was a project on squirrels
and I got to choose four different types
of squirrels and study what they ate and
where they lived and why they're all
different one of which is the prairie
dog which is not a dog it's actually a
squirrel but it's called a dog for its
warning call which actually sounds like
the bark of a dog I absolutely love this
project because learning more about
these furry creatures in the world
around me made me feel more connected
and that was a very powerful feeling but
in reflecting back on this project I
studied how these squirrels were
different and unique but all part of the
same family and at some level that's
also part of my own story of being
different and unique but in high school
I felt extremely ashamed about it so
this is one of the pictures with me and
my mom celebrating one of my earliest
birthdays and my mom who's in the
audience today she's Dutch European and
my dad is african-american and what
should have been a source of pride and
strength growing up was actually a
source of isolation and unworthiness my
curvy hips my mocha skin my hair were in
stark contrast to the standards of
beauty permeating the halls I absolutely
dreaded recess where I would have to
face interacting with my peers and have
questions like what are you your mom
talks funny you must be adopted those
questions only deepen the pain and the
rejection that I felt I needed an escape
and that escape took me to following an
academic inclination of mine which was
science and so the summer before my
senior year in high school I
participated in
young engineering and science scholars
program at Cal Tech and this program it
transformed my life to the very first
time I studied with other
underrepresented minorities and our
shared experiences they were empowering
I also got to conduct scientific
experimentation having to apply my mind
and my hands towards generating new data
and that feeling it was extremely
rewarding so rewarding that I end up
completing a PhD in science so I know
you're probably thinking maybe you have
an experienced science in the same way
and I get it but we are all connected to
science and at some level it has touched
you I will admit that as a scientist I
see the work for very strong scientific
lens but there are other things outside
of science and that's what I'm going to
call everything else now there's a third
really critical component to this and
that's you you make science actionable
and it's the intersection of all three
of these that I call snackable science
which is science that can enrich your
life and that you can manage and
bite-sized pieces I want to share with
you to pieces of snackable scientific
content into areas that we really care
about aging and relationships so as
humans we are living longer and that
often is correlated with a decline in
learning memory and attention science is
impacting this field by designing a tool
to counteract that loss and that
essentially is through video games so
neuro scientists at the ghazali lab at
UCSF created a video game designed to
improve multitasking and essentially
they have elderly participants play this
game by driving around and having to
identify different road signs what they
found with this game is that essentially
it could strengthen older brains to
acting younger not just at a behavioral
level so improving multitasking but also
at a functional level so it rewired the
brain so why is this important at a
scientific level this has to do
with plasticity which is essentially the
brain's ability to rewire itself by
enhancing cell to cell connections the
fact that they could do this in an elder
population is incredible and with video
games it's unimaginable in the wider
context this relates to aging and for
you this means play more video games
when backed of course by scientific
rigor the second piece of snackable
scientific content is in the realm of
relationships so we as humans are very
social beings we really thrive on our
relationships to one another especially
when there's mating involved scientists
that study waiting get really excited
about a certain type of rodent species
called the Prairie vole and that's
because there are two different types of
voles that exhibit drastically different
mating behaviors there is one vole that
stays with one partner for its entire
lifetime I'll call that the faithful
Bowl there's another vote however that's
pretty different it is rather from this
fewest and jumps around from partner to
partner so let's call that the frisky
Bowl what accounts for this difference
in behavior scientists have found that
it's neuro chemicals in their brain
essentially they've identified two
critical hormones called oxytocin and
vasopressin that are frowned at elevated
levels in the faithful bowl and can
actually induce faithful behavior when
elevated in the frisky bowl so why is
this important the scientific lens shows
us that while frisky behavior is often
associated with environmental factors
like culture or religion or
interpersonal dynamics amongst couples
science is telling us that there is a
strong scientific component that's
driven by neuro chemicals in the brain
in the wider context this relates to
relationships and for you this means
that for the very first time science has
created a real live love potion that can
induce faithful behavior in that special
someone what a treat that science is
giving
us so now that I've shared with you to
pieces of snackable scientific content I
want to show you how you can integrate
this into your life there's two
important things to keep in mind have a
snack daily and have a snack and
manageable bites it's about being
consistent and proactive and expanding
your appetite for a science in a way
that's personalized to your schedule
even if it means allocating five minutes
a week to learning one new scientific
fact it can have a huge amount of impact
one way of engaging in snackable science
is through an online blog that I've
created called dr. Jack's calm and
essentially this is my way of sprinkling
some scientific excitement into this
community I designed this blog with the
mission in mind that finds can and
should be a fun way for us to spend our
intellectual energy so my hope for you
at the end of this talk is that I've
made you hungry and that the next time
you find yourself at that vending
machine just craving a piece of
intellectual content that you'll be
brave enough to reach for science thank
you